Vladimir's Alinsky arrived to his
inauguration on foot
the crowds delighted with the man
they've known for years as a comic touch
on their TV screens he stopped for
selfies and high-fives
jumping to kiss members of the public
true man-of-the-people style staff the
crowds chanting zalenski as he took to
the red carpet and strode with panache
through the parliament
[Applause]
[Music]
all the traditional trappings of office
but an untraditional approach to
politics starting off with a rebuke to n
please
mal bran Yadav audit my election Only
Fools that the citizens are tired of the
experienced politicians who over the
past twenty eight years created a
country of opportunities opportunities
to steal bribe presidents Alinsky has
made ending the war in Ukraine's East
his priority he has promised to restart
dialogue with Russia on releasing
Ukrainian prisoners including the 24
sailors currently behind bars in Moscow
Russia is adopting a sit back and wait
approach the Kremlin said today that
Vladimir Putin would not send any
congratulations until Ukraine's new
president had proven his first successes
in resolving the conflict in eastern
Ukraine and mr. szalinski will be hard
pressed to compel the Kremlin to change
the status quo there for now his battle
is closer to home
there will be snap elections this summer
the new president needs parliamentary
seats and he'll be looking to capitalize
on his popularity before it starts to
fade dear nation throughout my life I've
been trying to do everything I can to
make Ukrainians smile
so I felt with my heart but it wasn't
just my job it was my mission in the
next five years I will do everything so
that you Ukrainians don't cry rain
should win the blood color yeah thank
you
the man who starred in a hit TV show as
a history teacher turned president now
inaugurated into the role for real
dynamic near Sky News Moscow